Yeah,
well I would say a smoking would be one,
uh,
eating to caloric excess would be
another,
um,
being sedentary,
uh,
not moving around,
not exercising would be a third.
We didn't talk about exercise,
but there's ample evidence that exercise
is beneficial.
Um,
I think the other thing is what we were
just talking about,
your attitude and mindset.
I think,
you know,
uh,
being focused on negativity would be a
fourth and I think the last one,
uh,
which again is what would be a more or
less in this lifestyle area would be
stress level.
This level of stress that you maintain
on a day to day basis.
So I believe in it.
Others a believe in something called
Hormesis
hormesis means is that a lot of stress
is a bad thing,
but no stress is also a bad thing and
the optimum is something in the middle
so that you're engaged on a daily basis.
It revved up your functioning.
Okay.
But you feel as though you're in
control.
And I think finding that balance that me
says,
uh,
is,
is probably very important in
maintaining a mental health and physical
health.
So that would be my,
my big five.